I don't know did they miss a trick not
calling it fantasy aroma disenchantment
Matt gray means latest animated series
debuted on Netflix and I thought to
myself wow check out an episode see what
I think and then several hours later I
watched the entire first season in one
day so yeah it certainly goes down
easily I'll give it that it's only ten
episodes long and they're short episodes
they're half hours I mean not even a
half hour I think they're 20 some-odd
minute
episodes so yeah it's pretty quick to
get through so what are my thoughts on
it it's a real good start is what it is
it reminds me in many ways of the first
season in Futurama and I'll be making
more than a couple Futurama comparisons
but when I say that what I mean is in
terms of sort of getting the obvious
jokes and obvious stories kind of out of
the way
cuz as much as I like Futurama and I do
like that first season you go back and
watch it most of the really obvious
stuff like the stuff that almost feels
obligatory if you're doing a future set
sci-fi comedy thing they're mostly in
the first season so that it felt it
feels looking back on it and a lot of
ways like the first season in Futurama
was clearing the deck of the obvious
stuff so that it's done and then they
can go to weirder and stranger places
and this has that same feel to it and it
also means as a result that it's not
quite as far out there as I'm hoping the
show will eventually get it's it's also
I don't want to say it's not as clever
as Futurama it might be not quite as
learning because one of the things about
Futurama was because they had a crap ton
of like science and math majors on the
writing staff and because it was a
sci-fi show there were a lot of deep cut
science and math jokes in that and you
know entire entire stories like like the
farnsworth peril box built around these
bizarre concept
insane mathematical equations that they
that they got me they invented there's
now Futurama theorem because of
something they did in one of their
episodes I think that was the prisoner
of benda was that one but sort of that
level of intellect isn't quite
undisplaced it's just because the
setting doesn't allow for it as much but
most of the rest is still present it it
it has the same age range for an
audience as well this isn't really for
kids again I would make the comparison
to Futurama there is a fair amount of
alcohol and drug related humour there is
a fair amount of alluded to sexual
activity not a lot explicitly shown and
there's a lot of death humor there's a
lot of really dark dark death humor but
it is all pretty funny
as far as characters go we've got
basically are three primary characters
our main character is a princess named
Tia beanie or bean is what most of them
call her and she is I was gonna see
she's kind of your typical rebellious
princess but she's not quite now explain
that in a bit but the other ones we have
elf Oh who's an elf yes they do address
how on the nose that is and he has
voluntarily left sort of the magical
hidden kingdom of the elves because he
was bored with how happy everything was
all the time and he goes out into the
world because he wants to experience
more nuance he actually wants to
experience sadness and and other things
and he's getting plenty of it so he's
just this little diminutive the guy who
doesn't really know what's going on and
gets kicked around a lot and then there
is a small sort of shadow demon kind of
guy that very unconvincingly passes
himself off as a cat who is kind of
bonded with bean because she's cursed
with a man his name is Lucy and I like
Lucy a lot so a instead like so Lucy is
very much the devil
on being shoulder he's always like
whisper your inner ear to it do it do it
do it do it to it he's that kind of guy
but he's also that he's got a little
more personality than that and he's he's
he's fun he's he's quite enjoyable I
think I'd like him best out of these
core 3 I do like being quite a bit
though elbow is usually good and when
the focus is on him a bit more he can be
a bit grading like imagine if if Ralph
Wiggum was a bit of a more central
character you kind of go oh yeah that
might be too much of you it's not quite
at that level but I was so the best
comparison I could come up with off off
the top of my head now coming back to
bean I'd said she is a little bit
different from your typical rebellious
princess and that's kind of true because
most stories of rebellious princesses
that I can think of that happen in
mainstream medium you know I mean like I
can't help but default to Disney but
Little Mermaid Aladdin tangled those
have varying degrees of rebellious
princesses but we're seeing them at the
start of their being actively rebellious
like first breaking free bean has been
very clearly pulling this for a while so
we didn't know what I thought based off
the trails we were gonna well I thought
it was gonna be was like she breaks free
out of this confined life and goes and
starts to experience all this stuff in
the world for the first time he's like
no she's gotta be doing this for a while
she does still have the combined life
when she sneaks out like almost every
night and gets drunk and starts fights
and she she is a rowdy rowdy person and
and is already established to be we're
not seeing the origins of this like no
this is her standard routine at this
point which I think it's kind of cool
and it's kind of fun as far as some of
the supporting ko and I also note that
night none of those three are any of
sort of the recurring graining voice
cast we do get some voice actors I'm
mainly from Futurama
on this but they're not any of the main
three which is good I think because the
most prominent of the voice cast from
Futurama in the supporting characters is
the king
who is voiced by John DiMaggio and I
actually yeah the voice of bender and I
actually find him really distracting as
far as this voice goes because it's it's
not that it's not the same as bender but
it's a very stock John DiMaggio voice
it's it's one of like a handful of one
I'm not saying these are the only voices
he can do but it's a handful of ones
that are very standard to him so I
caught it immediately that it was him
and it does kind of pull me out a little
bit and not that I'm saying you can't go
with your King in a medieval kind of
place talking like this but knowing who
it is I and maybe if you don't you know
watch as much animation maybe it's not
as distracting for me I found it really
distracting and it's not even a bad
performance but it just it that that
didn't quite work for me you've also got
like Maurice LaMarche
shows up as kind of a Vizier type
character which works it's like imagine
if if kif kroker had had backstabbing
ambitions there you go
and and tress MacNeille is all over the
place is you know your old women know
which of the cranky fairy and things
like that so you'll catch those voices
if you're a Futurama fan but like I said
thankfully it's not the main three which
again I think is a good call because I
think that would have been really
distracting so as far as the progression
of the thing overall I am going to get
into some spoilers towards the end of
the season on a couple things but I'll
warn you before I get there so the way
the season kind of progresses is
interesting because I it took me a while
to realize that it was actually building
a continuous story most of the episodes
feel if not 100% self-contained they
only feel like slightly following on
something that was set up in the last
one not in a to be continued way but in
a oh well that's that's the Nugget we're
gonna build a new episode from and the
next one just sort of very loose
connectivity because by and large most
episodes feel like they kind of reset to
zero again they sort of we start each
new episode with being you know being
out and
being rowdy and and the king being
grumpy at her and that's sort of the
standard starting point and what I
realized as the show went on is that it
actually been laying a fairly
significant amount of groundwork for
stuff that was going to be pulled
together later for the last couple of
episodes and I would say it actually
does it better than a lot of shows that
sort of take this stuff more seriously
like look I love Doctor Who but I hate
the way doctor who has done most of its
quote-unquote season arcs which is to
just continually drop a a name of
something that we don't know what it is
and then finally explain it at the end
you know like they did with bad wolf and
with with Torchwood and with hare and
would the name Harold Saxon and with the
you know the cracks and times you these
things we keep seeing and we don't find
out what it is until the very end
what disenchantment does instead is we
have something that is in an episode
plays its role in the episode gets used
you know okay but then ends up coming
back later along with a few other things
from a few out the representing you
realize oh they built a lot of
foundation back there without me
noticing nice work I think that's what
makes it kind of more impressive that
ways because what they weren't
signposting the stuff that was gonna
come back which was just kind of nice
and kind of it it had a respect for the
intelligence of the audience that I
guess I I don't always realize how much
that's lacking until I see a show that
that actually expects a little bit more
out of its audience in terms of
connecting the dots so well done there
oh yeah I don't wanna I don't want to
oversell because overall there there
weren't a ton of
gut-busting moments for me as far as the
humor goes but it was all pretty good
very few things landed with a thud and
I'm still I'm still you know getting my
investment into the character so it's
not quite bringing the heavier emotional
stuff out of me which again to make the
Futurama comparison the real heavy
emotional Futurama episodes of which
there are quite a few and they're
excellent don't really start hitting
until like maybe season 3 and onward
first couple of seasons is is you know
just getting to know these folks
and that's the same here I'm gonna talk
about a couple of things that I actually
have a little bit more issue with but
they're all they're kind of spoilery so
my overall thing is go check it out it's
a low time investment you'll know in the
first three or four episodes if you're
enjoying it and if it's just uh it's
okay just go on through to the end I I
think it's worth it for that and I'm
looking forward to a second season so
getting into spoilers there's two things
that I didn't particularly care for the
first has to do with alpha which is elf
Oh develops a crush on bean and I don't
like that for a number of reasons it
just feels very forced it feels like it
feels like a an attempt to recreate the
the fry Leela dynamic in terms of the
guy who has no chance with this girl and
she's just she just sees him as a friend
and and I obviously that that developed
over a fair amount of time on Futurama
into something else but I the one thing
I'll say is that it is a little bit
fresher here in that it feels like we're
getting it from the other side because
Futurama was primarily from Fry's
perspective and we were sympathizing
with him whereas distant Jim is
primarily from beans perspective and we
sort of get a bit more of the sense of
oh well boy you're cute but you're
annoying and we're not being asked to to
feel bad for him
because she doesn't want to be with him
too the same way that we kind of were
with Fry so I mean that that freshens it
up a little bit but it just strikes me
as highly unnecessary especially within
the within the first season I mean it is
important to have them connect and have
them be friends but I don't think it was
necessary for him to actually develop a
crush on her it just yeah I think it was
just a step too far and wasn't necessary
I mean we'll see where it goes
ultimately but I would much rather have
seen a dynamic of them just being great
friends personally the other thing that
was a little bit iffy is at the very end
in the last episode stuff that goes on
with beans mother so if you're watching
this and you don't care about spoilers
but you didn't watch the show
beans mother was presumed dead through
pretty much the whole season until it
of our end we find out that this statue
that we had assumed was a monument for
her is in fact her mother turned to
stone and beam has the chance LFO dyes
beam has the chance to either resurrect
el foe or bring back her mother and she
had been turned to stone because she had
been hit with a poison intended for the
king and being chooses to bring back her
mother now that choice in and of itself
cool I loved I love the tension of that
and I think it's very sympathetic the
choice that she made and but also
understanding why it was a hard choice
for her to make I like all of that but
then once I would say within two minutes
of the mother being back I was like
she's gonna turn out to be evil and and
then like another minute after that I'm
gonna be like that poison that was meant
for the King she did that and then she
drove drank from the wrong Cup and I was
right and it's I don't know it just felt
I don't want to say it was predictable
but it felt over telegraphed it really
felt like that was a part where the
respect for the intelligence of the
audience felt like it pulled back a
little bit because they really they over
hinted at this I think at least for me
if it got other viewers off-guard I'd
kind of like to hear about that but I I
feel like it's within within a couple
minutes of her being resurrected I
called pretty much the entire rest of it
I do find the place that it ends to be
pretty interesting because this is a
serious status quo shake-up and where
it's gonna start next season can't be
where it ended so I will be super
curious about where things go from here
but yeah those are really kind of only
my only two major notes other than that
it was it's good it was solid and you
know not phenomenal but I think a lot of
really good strong groundwork that could
turn into something special in another
season or two so I'm certainly gonna be
keeping my eye on and as I said I
recommend people check it out so
disenchantment season 1 have you seen it
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do and you know what it is you
don't need me to tell you about there's
links for all of it down in the
description and there's buttons feel
free to click some of them I have a
patreon I'll single that out but other
than that check it out if you care and
remember folks you are the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]